now remember chris we just used to have
a podcast right yep we were in a shower
curtain we were in a tiny little
vo booth back in the day and we were the
only one at nfl media group to have one
that's true
and we kept expanding the brand until we
then were doing the podcast as well as a
weekly television television
then because the thursday night football
we became just a a sort of once every
now and then sort of like a barbara
walters special type thing
like seven or eight turning out the
podcast and
who is the only one talking about the
podcast internally and
on the air on nfl network well you that
would be me yeah because my phrase is if
not me who and if not now
when that's true how did it sometimes
twist the arms of
people say can i mention it on the air
but i just decided to screw it up keep
doing it
the amount of crap that i would get from
my on-air compadres
marshall was a was a major violator of
this
mooch kurt on occasion
michael irvin would just chime in he
wasn't leading that charge if oh do you
have a podcast do you have a podcast
i didn't know you had a podcast even
though they fully knew i had a podcast
on though now who's got a podcast hey
the michael irvin podcast
launching this week michael irvin
podcaster extraordinaire on the rich
eisen show
how are you erv chris how are you man
that was that was great rich you know
and since i
do have a podcast and and getting into
business
that right there yes that's a great it's
just a great way
you know when i was when i was shooting
it and stephen a he gave me something
right in the midst
of it you know about about the business
of
hosting yes you see you see that
talented gift that what you just did you
brought yesterday
and placed it on today and you use it in
a way that we drew the audience back to
where we used to be and as we pray
that's just brilliant stuff buddy i
appreciate that but you look like
i'm getting in the business rich i can't
i'm learning so now i want to apply
well so here's the thing michael is
because you know uh there
there may be an i in rich and eisen in
the same way that there are
two eyes in irvine and you can't spell
michael without me
i am still a team player had you told me
that steven a was your first guest i
would have worked that
into game day morning yesterday first
hour when stephen a
tweeted at you and we put the tweet on
like i would have
i would have put it all together i would
have made that not only quality content
for our show
but also a not so passive aggressive
promotion for your podcast i'm i'm here
for you mike just
feed me the information help me help you
is what i'm saying
i i appreciate that rich and you know
what's so funny you bring that up rich
because
and all that seriousness and what i say
you know i i text
stephen a that when we put i said man i
missed the moment right there yes and i
said
i said i said i i know you would have
gotten it
and i know rich would have gotten it but
i missed it
i promise you i just sent you the text
that i text you
back right there's some things i need to
learn
in that aspect but but that's the fun
part of it that's interesting that you
bring that
okay you knew in advance that he was
going to be your first guest as of
yesterday or please tell me
the cowboys recent exploits in seattle
had not yet happened and you are
going to speak to stephen post week
three action
no no no no no no actually no i i wanted
all of that
in there you know i thought it would be
a disservice to him
to do it right after week two
and the jubilance of the atlantic
victory
so we wanted to give some you know give
some siblings to it so we waited
to after the game yesterday and then
and and and that's a good call that's a
good call because there's a lot in there
there's a lot in there so i guess i can
tell you yes
again i get so heated with them i seem
to always
sweat whenever we're getting it
i was sitting here saying to myself rich
looking at my [ __ ] why am i sweating
like this you know
why am i sweating but yeah we we talk
about it pretty heavy the host of the
michael irvin podcast launching this
very thursday october 1st michael irvin
here on the rich eisen show
first guest stephen a smith so i guess
it's only fitting
potentially for me to start my interview
with you post week three
dallas at seattle with this very
question
how about that cowboys
okay what's the good place explain me
the good place
well would you not say
the cowboys by far by far
did not play nowhere near their best
games
the number of penalties mistakes that
were made in that game
things that as you go through this
season they are correctable
they are correctable at least you can
work on being better and those are in
those things
but also you must say that
that seattle team and russell wilson is
incredible it's just
freaking incredible man i tweeted i said
you know you can't leave rush
three to seven but you gotta make rush
has to have to go score a touchdown
and come back to score again when he
gets the ball with five minutes left you
got to make it almost impossible
anything within the realm he'll get it
done
phil gold touchdown that that's nothing
to him he's just so incredible you know
what i mean
and he and his team dk metcalf he's
probably the best receiver in the nfl
right now so incredible right now and
they are all of that
and the cowboys made all of those
mistakes that are correctable
then we're saying the same thing the
cowboys are going to be where they want
where they need to be they just got to
correct those mistakes
that was the number one team in the nfc
right now at them in the packers
so in the packer no i i agree with you
we play away
from you know extending that game i'm
just giving
or winning no i know and russell's been
an equal opportunity destroyer
no doubt about it but my question for
you erv is are you not concerned about
the back end of this defense
at all oh absolutely absolutely but i
knew that was that
i we knew that was that it's
the back end is real bad the background
is bad so how is that correct that's why
and that's why i even even when rich
when they were talking earl you know
earl's a difference maker i believe in
that sense even though people say well
he's not the same
uh you know physical dude maybe he's
lost something
physically but understanding of the game
little ways that he has used to trick
quarterbacks
you can give these young guys that are
running around
like they don't know what's going on
that
that knowledge is what i was hoping that
they would get
so you think they should so you think
would you counsel jerry to go get him
right now if they could fit him in
oh i i i i i hope jerry would do that
i hope jay will do it now this i i
haven't spoken to him
right i don't know anything what's going
on with him
but i'm just speaking what what i what i
would hope for that backfield to get
because it's not just when people see
you getting beat that way
that's not just a physical thing
that's also a mental thing you know
that's that's a mental thing
right you see d.k metcalf coming running
across that whole zone
all the way to the back it's a certain
thing is how you position yourself
what kind of film have you seen or you
know the cut down on the possibilities
of you thinking that anything can happen
if every time he lines up this in his
position i only see him running
a slant or a deep end so now i can focus
on
you know what i'm saying right little
things
that could help them use their physical
skill set
better he can give them michael irvin
here on the rich eisen show check out
the michael irvin podcast starting this
very thursday i'm very excited for you
erv with stephen a smith as his first
guest
right here on the rich eisen show what
did you make of today's news that matt
neggie
is going with foals in the future and
the fact that he went to foals at all
yesterday
irv well you knew what this was about
we all knew what this was about you know
it's trubisky okay here it is
we're giving you this opportunity but
we're going to get him
just in case you don't man up to the
opportunity
and and obviously and it was hard on
is is they're looking at the others
place and saying wow
those other two guys that we let get
away
you know you can't help but do it
because you can't control your brain
when your eyes see it on tv
you can't say brain don't think it in
the brain don't think it doesn't work
that way
it doesn't work that way the brain
started thinking you can't control that
so
you know that must be running running
them kind of out of their heads and
yeah yeah you know they had opportunity
and and when you see guys step up their
play when somebody comes on the field
that says something too you know what i
mean richard
yeah i know i know that what so uh what
do you think's going on in philadelphia
um where again um wentz has just been
struggling
yesterday we talked about it during the
show and we saw that he
um you know needed five quarters to
tie cincinnati today
doug peterson's saying don't even go in
the direction of jalen hurts we're going
to fix this with him
you know is that a locker room thing you
think it's a contract thing what do you
think it
is happening there in philadelphia
michael i i think it has to be all of
the above
certainly they're trying to make sure
that
after making a commitment so short time
ago
that that they don't bail on that
commitment already
i i now now that that's what they have
to do but why why is it happening is
another thing
why is it happening what's going on you
know it started out
first of all everybody talked about the
off-season but then they went through a
still going through a rash of injuries
you know so so how do you even make
how do you even say we're gonna move on
from this kid in the midst of all of
this
you know that could that could be
something so yeah i understand what they
what what they're doing
but but but now if something happens you
know
i don't know you get a thumbnail or
take a bad hit god forbid and get a
concussion and then jalen hurts goes in
a game
and he tears it up then the problem
really
really starts right now they can control
the problem
but if it's an unfortunate situation it
could
expose something real a real issue
like what well
if jalen hurts if something happens to
carson wentz right who
unfortunately has gotten hurt before and
they have to play jaylen hurts and jalen
hurts goes in
and he plays well and he turns it around
now now they can't just say
it's not carson wentz they would have to
address that
you see what i'm saying well i guess
then why draft somebody at all
and then if what could happen to carson
wentz's ineffectiveness
and your season's going down the tubes
but also i guess on the back end
they're really only half game behind
your dallas cowboys so
and that's the kicker it's okay to be
stressed
but don't panic because right now and
that's what i try to tell everybody
the object is not to to go undefeated
is to get in the playoffs and so you
have time coming off that off season
to get it right if you are the eagles or
if you are the cowboys right now
honestly
you just gotta you're trying to fight to
beat the east you beat the east to get
in the playoffs and
and right now that's why they're not
going crazy now the cowboys were three
and oh
and they were going through this and uh
or the giants were three and oh
and they were going through that they'll
be pressed
it would be press rich to try to think
about doing stuff now
you know a few minutes left here with
michael irvin on the rich eisen show
michael i've been working with you for
so long i kind of know what you're
thinking before you're thinking it
and i know what you're saying without
trying to say it so yesterday
you didn't dig a hole for drew brees um
and you didn't bury him but it sure
seemed like you were reaching for the
shovel
in yesterday's game day morning i wonder
what you thought of his performance on
sunday night football
and if you're going to reach for the
shovel to start digging a hole for drew
brees
michael listen i didn't reach for
shovel i think you did i think you did i
added no
no i brought up the realities of what we
saw
they didn't what everybody saw you know
and i know that was a games first game
without michael thomas and everything
but it showed
what what makes this offense go and they
used that short passing game
to to to like like a run game also look
at yesterday
where did all those passes go they went
to the running back
adam come on it's still a short passing
game it's
you know what i'm saying i looked up
when it would trip me out
when i would look up and and you know
chase mill getting some runs i said okay
i'm how much they're putting him in the
game they're getting it
are they get him in the game to get the
ball down the field i'm just saying but
that was a great game last night now
i was i i i agree that was a great game
so where do you stand on brees i know
that again your your
your stances well we always want to see
this this is what it is
rich this is what it is we want to
always
it's okay to love heroes and and think
and think
and and and you know be inspired by them
but the growth of them also
like are the different places they go to
peyton manning threw the ball
all over the field but in the end he won
with what we know gave him the ability
to throw the ball all over the field
which was his mind because he couldn't
throw the ball all over the field
anymore so it's great drew brees was
able to throw the ball all over the
field
but maybe some of the physical aspects
aren't there
so he we can admire the other greatness
in him
is his mind peyton won his last year he
didn't throw it all over
he just didn't put him in bad plays and
right now
since drew is in a position to make
plays to win
some of that is being exposed are you
calling him a game manager michael is
that what you just did did you oh
yes that ain't rogers hey
was i the only one that brought in the
aaron rodgers
well we were talking about pre-season is
it what you're saying
well kurt kurt knocked the packers out
of the playoffs
and i i i no yesterday mooch
uh was lone wolf in the saints yesterday
uh but in terms of the season in terms
of the nfc north i think you did
and i would love to take that back i
would love love
love to have my mulligan i would even
give up my super bowl mulligan
for thanksgiving show that we do every
year i would give up that mulligan to
put the packers in the nfc north right
now from our pre-season show if i'd be
allowed to
use my mulligan now i'd do that right
now and just
rip the knob off i missed it did you say
that's the one who did you have in the
north
africa are the vikings i had the vikings
[Music]
oh my gosh no rogers looks amazing
before i let you go
irv you are lone wolfing the chiefs
tonight um
i gave you the floor on what you think
happens on monday night and why you like
the chiefs to win this game
and i find that so amazing that i am
long-willed for the chief you are
when he when he's never beat patrick
mahomes
you know what i'm saying because patrick
can beat you
like the old candy like the old candy
that i grew up
and i love that candy that now and later
you got a backpack on my bike you know
eat some now and i eat some later
patrick mahomes can beat you now or he
can beat you later he can beat you early
in the game by throwing the ball all
over the field
or he can come back and beat you later
even if you go
up some point we don't know
how great those moments
lamar jackson is so i'm gonna take two
moments and i know in this great moment
in this great moment i'm talking about
coming from behind for lamar jackson
when you take his running out and it's
all air raid
you take that out how how how impactful
he can be
but now i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna
tell you right now i'm gonna take this
moment
to see the greatness in patrick the
homes now that
everybody is picked against him
the man just got 500 million dollars he
was supposed to be to be loved
everybody supposed to all patrick
mahomes
and now here comes uh lamar jackson
and everybody wants to pick against this
man
i say he will reach down inside himself
and show you that i am still the
quarterback
the face not of this franchise in kansas
city
but the three letters caught n
f l that's what we're about to see
tonight round of applause for michael
irvin everybody
irv that's the sort of stuff that you're
gonna get that's the sort of stuff
you're gonna get
um in the michael irvin podcast and
congrats on the you
crushing it this weekend over florida
state they just smoked it oh my god
yeah we finally got a quarterback man
and actually that kid's playing well man
it's good to see him
you know just get that feeling of
winning again we just got to try to hold
on to it
okay irv you know what why did they call
it now and later is it because you could
have it now or later because it was such
a hard candy that it didn't matter that
there's no such thing as freshness you
can have it now
or later or because it was such a hard
candy you could eat it now
and half of it would stick to your teeth
so you could pluck it out and eat it
later is that what they would call it an
hour later is it
what are they calling out it's a very
good analysis right they're original i
don't know except for an hour
later i just thought because they had a
few single wrapped
candies yes in a wrapping yes they were
not ready they were all singly wrapped
singularly wrapped yes so you can have
some now
keep it in your pocket have some later
and then when you talk
right and when you talk about the bully
chuck uh
that you want teams to become the bully
in the nfl and you tell the story on
game day morning
chuck was the bully who took your now
and laters from you correct
back in the day chuck was it chuck was
the truck was the bully
who we tried to bribe with the now and
later
not to pull me up
okay yeah i want to get that up now and
later okay
is chuck the second guest on your
podcast who's gonna get you
you're gonna get chuckles
i'll do it any time or if you know that
you've been great to me i'll do it
anytime
if you ever need a guest i'll be there
for you oh absolutely buddy
you better believe that we're definitely
going love your take care i'll see you
on the zoom on saturday i love you too
man
and thanks for everything rich thank you
for everything man your friendship your
love
all the knowledge all everything but
right back at you there's michael irving
everybody right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here